then this hypothetical guy 41 comes in
with an air of humility but
inquisitiveness and they make their
intention clear but not overbearing
about it right and there's a there's a
certain thing to be said for having
confidence in your action
don't look for a lot of reassurance
because while the train is moving
there's no time for people to stop and
pat you on the head
i will because that's how i manage but
there are a lot of people who have
multiple shows going and don't have time
and don't
really acknowledge
when you're doing well unless you ask
when i was first coming up one of the
things that i would do is i would ask
for performance reviews from the people
i was working with
what can i do to do a better job for you
is there anything you've noticed that i
might be more effective if i tried
coming at something a different way and
just trying to keep to just open a
dialogue too
um it enables you to develop friendships
with the people who are above you
professional friendships
and it also establishes for them that
you're somebody who has a desire for
growth
and
you know how can you not want to help
somebody who is earnest
about wanting to move up and move
forward
all of us need
to realize this is a broader thing this
this is this is for film and television
in general
one of the greatest gifts in my life
is that i'm a member of something called
the caucus for producers writers and
directors
the people who have our members in this
organization are typically older than i
am
they've been working a lot of them since
you know the 50s 60s 70s 80s they've
seen the business change they know how
much ground producers have lost
they know things that are important and
they have big picture things that they
can tell you they can give you advice
you can't get from anyone else
the idea of i'm going to come in and
show them how great i am
that a lot of people who are new to any
business have
if you forget to seek out a mentor
you've made a huge mistake if you fail
to take advantage of the interactions
with the more experienced people above
you you are failing as a creative no
matter
what corner of the industry you're in
seek out those people who know
and learn from them
don't come in again with that agenda
that you're going to change the world
and introduce something that no one has
ever seen before
because we are in a business where a lot
of it depends on the familiar
is if something looks too
bizarre or too outlandish it's not
accepted right away it's a harder sell
and definitely if you're working in a
collaborative environment
the idea that you're the rock star with
the great ideas doesn't always work in a
collaborative
medium
can you give me some examples on how to
maybe temper
that because i think generation y and
then of course myself generation x we've
been taught sort of that you know don't
show any weakness kind of attitude where
maybe baby boomers are more willing to
talk about things so how can someone
temper that if they have that in them
well i would tell you there i think that
there's a difference between
coming in and saying i don't understand
how this works
and coming in and saying listen
i'm having a little bit of trouble with
this thing here in your experience how
have you dealt with this got it okay
that's not weakness the seeking of
knowledge is not weakness
refusing to acknowledge your weaknesses
is weakness okay so you have to you have
to be able to to go to people and say
i need a little bit of your
understanding here
you know